[Music]
here two thai chicken come on this is so and
here from the metallic must
how logged in me must not those
messages that we are already close
old van is disappearing
[Music]
[Applause]
here is a
free inside can you can a buddy of
want your way
look straight what you about parents more about
if light
pony knows you can
turn that
[Music]
faust that's a piece full of understanding and
has and
riso look wigwam i had more could get it off
come but i walk anti wrinkle  can you
no longer thomas at home i also have them
here grab your leg and you had a light
foil and bag
lying i have again is that you
had to hit it this is he for more but that
light has to be in low light  is
[Music]